olá caros amigos
sua mãe quem me falou nada que seja
muito menos a mais um bebê e hoje
pessoal nós vamos fazer uma maldade é
que é um membro da casa que vai ser um
golpe neste caso eu aproveitei que não
está em casa porque eu tenho pra fechar
o caso foi lá que eu vou fazer é não só
que eu tenho aqui
aí qualquer roots produto incrível
cumprir já não vai ser hoje mais perto
você sua loteria que três pacotes
baratas são muitas baratas e o que eu
vou fazer é espalhar pela casa mãe do
bebê porque nós a embrapa não tem muitos
nomes como 99% das pessoas eu confesso
que já perdeu um pouco nos das baratas
porque o elemento a minha tranquila com
baratas todos os dias portanto é
elétrico podendo num mas como vai
funcionar o solo já disse vou falar isso
pela casa de banho do bingo aproveitar
que não está em casa
goulart estudo a mas lá pelo meio vou
deixar uma das baratas verdadeiras é eu
quando entrar na casa de banho vai
perceber rapidamente questões físicas e
não vai ter tanta graça assim o apelo
mas se não vira uma barata tirou a
história muito então essa vai ser
presente hoje mas as pessoas já deixou
sulik no canal foram inscritos que não
espera é e cometem mais pessoal pra que
vocês querem que eu faça o pior tanto o
zouk seu argumento tem só eu vou tentar
fazer as coisas que vocês pedem ó
pessoal pedia que faltava aqui maior
portanto vou aproveitar eu acho que
temos suficiente preocupar os filhos na
casa do bairro de agora a ajuda dela que
embora lá falou
[Música]
não há nada a fazer
hoje eu fiz uma pré campanha da cdu casa
foi a aac no juvenil e honesta é
advogado a lei nos dá confiança vamos
falar estuda nem dormir sem eu
continuava bastante está essa coleta
méxico ano mas a casa bandida vou largar
uma ou duas paradas brasileiras ano
choveu tem mais precisa da minha ajuda
para core i5 são muito ricas não vou
pagar mais barato não sei se pegou a
votar no seu boca e deixar meu louco
credo parece não entrar aqui tem 1.000
baratos comigo
meu nome da menina também branco no chão
do banheiro ganhou hoje o grande uso de
nenhuma base no texto que nunca pensaram
que tinham tudo não tenho nenhum eu
nunca vai encontrar essa
todas as vezes que ele encontrou
assustar já saí já saiu daqui outra
assim parece ter um bicho lá fora eu
estava muito 3d 3d em qualquer coisa
estranha
[Risadas]
agora vou aproveitar essa especulação é
que nos fácil porque não vai estar à
espera que haja baratas aqui para lá
eu quando cheguei a esta peça de roupa
barata
eu já sei a coisa que mais gosta os
times do le iene
quando você vê na praça da bandeira da
ram meu que nojo pessoal esta é frank
martin gente sempre olha aí
e isso é o resultado final o pessoal da
casa branca já está cheio de baratas e
agora vai ser um procedimento mais
nojento porque agora sim eu vou à
academia terá um dos caras mais baratas
verdadeiras não vamos ver o que isto vai
dar
vamos para o pessoal das baratas
eu acho que deve estar lá em cima que
elas podem sempre elas fazem sempre para
um buraco ali mas eu não vou encontrar
vou só tirar das linhas brancas
você quer gente mas eu vou usar um copo
do lixo não faz parte da segunda etapa
da ação hoje a sério e siga-nos 2010
esse grupo tem sido na falha do ju não
para mac mac an iomaire 321 bairro
qualquer pessoa pode acionar o ipca
agora
quem já foi ver o que se passa na casa
de banho
não vou falar agora negado porque
conseguimos marcar porque é isso que eu
vou acabar com minha mãe é uma peça de
cada curso de artes do pará de gaza que
seria seguido não aquela que o estado é
que ela tá e essa aqui também está agora
está aqui ou aqui eu digo em 3d
a queda em 13 rodadas o que não não não
isso aqui que é isso aqui e por isso é
verdade que hoje não teve a mão
arrancada que nojo
é só uma brincadeira tirando aquilo no
qual o filme é a nossa aqui eles vão
chamar de irmão
[Música]
hoje começa por ele é porque ele é todo
em azul porque os urubus love foi na
casa de ângelo antônio o tamanho da
equipe x cfc é barata esmagadas que nos
deu naquela hora não sabia disso existe
um roteiro não tem tudo mas fora dele se
manter na série a não ser manter sendo
que nos fala que eu deixei 3 baratos e
só encontrei três moradas
vamos jogar com a força ele é um cara
bom treinando enquanto a deus eu não
queria doar vou tentar vou tentar
arranjar tem nenhuma
faltam duas
já os lados foi a escola mais humana
está na roma mas eu não consegui
encontrar por lá têm apenas 1%
nestas cinco décadas aquele cara que não
tem nada a ver com isso
só pra quem decorou melhor do que eu
pensava que ia de swap que eu tinha três
baratas ela na casa de banho agora vai
estar doido à procura do último e só com
um super benfica tem estado já sabe se o
vosso laico momento em que os vossos
amigos onde não sabe exatamente só
comenta em mais frentes para fazer o
pior então quero que fique bem e até a
próxima